it looks like yet another piece of that
infamous Christopher steel Trump Russia
dossier the one that the trumpets have
been sort of going apoplectic to try to
debunk for months now another element of
it seems to have been proven true or at
least corroborated and you might
remember you might not that one of the
assertions of the steel dossier was
about the involvement of Blackwater
founder Eric Prince in trying to set up
a back-channel between the Russian
Kremlin and then president-elect Trump
it was in January of 2017 before the
inauguration of Trump that supposedly
Eric Prince was trying to set up this
back-channel and as a quick reminder
Blackwater is the mercenary firm often
hired by the US government
Eric Prince is its founder he also
happens to be the brother of Secretary
of Education Betsy DeVos which is a
story for a different day if that's new
information to you and after the dossier
surfaced alleging that prince tried to
set up this back-channel prince denied
it
his attorney denied it and we now have a
new report months and months later which
says that Robert Muller might already
have evidence that indeed Eric Prince
did exactly this tried to establish this
back channel between the Trump
transition team and Kremlin operatives
and the Washington Post has a great
story on it where they report that a
witness who is cooperating with Robert
Muller's investigators says yeah the
meeting took place and the meeting took
place in January of 2017 and what Eric
prince told congressional investigators
he didn't deny that the referenced
meeting happened he denied that it was
planned saying instead oh it was a
totally chance encounter and also denied
that it had anything to do with US
Russia relations visa vie the
inauguration of President Donald Trump
but that happens to be the exact
opposite of what this cooperating
witness has told Robert Muller according
to the Washington Post report and
according to the witness the meeting was
not a chance encounter it was set up in
advance and it was
specifically set up so that a
representative of trumps transition team
would meet a delegate from Russia
specifically to figure out how to
communicate in the future and we're now
getting beyond sort of circumstantial
inaccuracies or something you could
write off to a semantic disagreement
right there's no way that we can say
semantics explains the difference
between Erik Prince's version of events
and this cooperating witnesses version
of events you can't say the language was
ambiguous there are somebody is flat-out
lying here if these are the assertions
that have been made by each party either
it was a planned meeting or it was a
chance encounter that Erik Prince
absolutely did not expect if it's a
planned meeting then Erik Prince
directly lied to investigators and
that's something that usually ends up
with you having a pretty bad time and
this also sort of more broadly shows the
consistent pattern by Trump associates
to try to create back channels right
because it's not just Erik Prince from
Blackwater accused of trying to create a
back channel to Russia you might
remember that the exact same accusation
exists against Donald Trump's son-in-law
Jared Kushner the accusation that he met
with Russian ambassador Sergei kis lyac
to do almost this exact same thing
potentially on a sort of more ongoing
basis than just for the transition
period Kushner was looking at doing this
at creating this back channel to the
Kremlin specifically to get around
American intelligence agencies awareness
of what it is that they're doing and as
I read about this there's no way that
Moeller's team is just feeling around
right I mean they clearly know what is
going on and are trying to see who's
lying about this at this point last week
we kind of talked about it and I pointed
out and it's not something that I came
up with uniquely right I mean it's
widely known that when investigators at
this level the the investigators working
at the level of Robert Muller when they
asked questions they asked questions
typically that they already know the
answers to to try to figure out who is
lying and where there are disagreements
or inconsistencies but they must
in this case what the truth is and I
would love to see Eric prints taken down
reportedly a multi-billionaire just like
his sister Betsy DeVos who has made just
disgusting amounts of money basically
selling private war services to
governments including the government of
the United States and if you're
wondering what's going on with
Blackwater these days I haven't heard
much about it that's because they've
changed their name Blackwater
technically no longer exists it was
first called Blackwater it was then
renamed Z Services like X E even more
innocuous and then later renamed Academy
with an AI most companies don't want to
be regularly changing names because you
sort of build brand awareness and
recognition under one particular name
this is the opposite a cat when you hear
the name Academy with an AI you say
Blackwater and mercenary services and
private war contracting that doesn't
sound at all like a company that would
be doing that that's exactly what they
want and indeed Blackwater as black
water doesn't even exist anymore yeah
that's a problem and also we know that
patronage and nepotism is rampant yeah
this White House do you think this
connection led to Betsy DeVos becoming
the education secretary that's been the
speculation for a while I mean she her
husband and her I mean she has got a ton
of money as well I don't want to make it
seem like it's the guy who wears a
million dollar they both between them
were donating the max2
Trump and cronies and whatever so yeah I
mean certainly I would speculate that
the Eric prince connection is a
connection that was relevant for her but
also she and her husband were donating
big bucks to Trump so I think there's no
question that she had no business being
Secretary of Education there's no doubt
about that
how she got into the position could have
been Eric Prince could have been because
of her donations who knows at this point
but yet another piece of the steel
dossier reportedly corroborated the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership